what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so getting into the unworthy Thor
versus the Mighty Thor from Marvel
generations this again is one of those
stories that picks up after secret
Empire we finish secret Empire that's
all done you'll find that playlist down
in the description but that playlist is
designed to start with secret Empire in
the stories that led into it and then go
all the way through more of a legacy
Marvel generations that kind of a thing
now a lot of people speculate that
secret Empire was basically supposed to
lead into an era where it was basically
like Dark Reign for the most part but
the idea is that because of the backlash
of secret Empire that Marvel basically
changed it and so what we ended up
getting was like Marvel legacy where
things were basically supposed to be
like Marvel's version of DC rebirth
generations is what leads into legacy is
kind of like this these connecting
stories and what they do is they're
really just one shots and they feature
of the current roster of characters
teaming up with their original
characters now the way this goes is this
really focuses on of course unworthy
Thor who's basically Odin's son who in
the current story arcs cannot wield his
hammer and then Jane Foster Thor who is
the one picking up the hammer of Thor
but the idea here is that this focuses
on these two characters meeting each
other from two different eras in time
and so this initially picks up with
Odin's son back when he was younger
trying to pick up his hammer now the
funny thing about this is that writer
Jason Aaron really kind of being like
the foremost writer on Thor at the
moment the guy who wrote you know really
started with Thor god of thunder who's
been riding everything going into the
current story ox right now he's drawing
inspiration from a particular story but
also changing it one of the biggest
misconceptions about Odin's son is that
people will say that he went through
like all these trials and tribulations
and struggles and different things like
that in order for him to be able to pick
up his hammer that's actually not true
after the events of Thor Ragnarok when
Marvel basically removed Odin's son from
the landscape what they ended up doing
was releasing like all these little mini
stories things like that just to keep
Thor fresh in the mind of people so that
one Civil War ended and Odin's son came
back it would be a highly anticipated
thing what they ended up doing was
publishing one story who was actually a
twelve part series called Thor son of
Asgard now the funny thing about this is
that it was written by a guy named Akira
Ishida people say he's fake they say
like is basically basically a writer
that Marvel invented I don't know that's
true or not but one of those weird
conspiracy theories but what this story
basically did is a detail
how Thor became worthy was basically
Loki's safe and Odin son going off and
fighting a dragon or something like that
Odin son still couldn't lift his hammer
so he went to go see the nornes and they
basically said look SIF is gonna be
kidnapped by frost giants you're gonna
go rescue her and that's what's gonna
make you worthy literally he fell in
love with a chick he saved her from
frost giants and so he was worthy to
wield his hammer it was never a great
big huge drawn-out thing but what this
does is it kind of goes back to that and
it seems to like remove that from the
landscape now we're not told why Onan
son can't lift his hammer other than the
fact that he's not worthy and so because
of that he's just not able to pick it
out so it's still very much a driving
force in terms of his character in terms
of him trying to do what it is that he
can do now of course this goes directly
into the idea that like Odin is
basically being a jerk
Odin is like the the father is trying to
instill discipline in his son and his
sons like I really don't want to have
anything to do with that now keep in
mind this is not out of the character
for own son Odin son when he was younger
was basically foolhardy he was brash he
would go out and just do these
ridiculous things and he was really more
arrogant and cocky than anything else in
order to teach him what it meant to be
humble the idea was put forward that
Odin had basically put Thor in the body
of a guy named Donald Blake in order to
teach him what it meant to basically be
powerless but the idea here is that with
these delegation of gods you know
showing up Thor basically disobeys his
dad and he's like whatever man I just
want to go have fun now this comes by
way of the fact that Thor actually
overhears a prayer from a Viking Odin's
son can hear the prayers of people on
earth sometimes he'll answer sometimes
he won't but in this instance he
basically just hears a prayer from a
Viking saying hey look we decided we
wanted to invade Egypt and we came
across a guy that we can't beat so like
maybe Thor will help us and so of course
when Odin the son shows up we basically
end up finding out that this is
Apocalypse Now my initial thought when I
first saw this is okay maybe Jason Aaron
is retconning something else but what
they actually do is reference uncanny
Avengers now for those of you guys who
don't know and who never read that story
uncanny Avengers basically offered an
explanation for the battle ax of yarn
Bjorn when it comes to Odin's son's
character the hammer is the most
recognizable weapon and he possesses but
yarn Bjorn the battle actually uses is
actually in a lot of ways just as
capable if not a little more capable and
the reason why is because originally
yarn born was just a battle ox it was
just a piece of metal attached to a
stick and Thor would
use it to like fight bad guys it was
basically the weapon he used and the
time when he was waiting to be able to
wield his hammer but what ended up
happening in uncanny Avengers is there
was a story where we basically jumped
back into the past and we found that
Thor fought apocalypse for the very
first hunt the problem with this is that
because apocalypse uses celestial
technology basically technology
belonging to a super advanced and
insanely powerful alien race it
basically made him impervious to any of
the damage the Thor could possibly
inflict on him using yarn Bjorn and so
because of this Odin son basically went
back and had the the ax magically
enchanted it's now one of the most
prominent weapons that he uses because
of this in the midst of this battle of
course Odin's son makes reference to
facing off against apocalypse again now
of course this basically coincides with
the arrival of Jane Foster now this is
the ongoing theme of generations the
newer characters are basically just
thrust into the past and exist alongside
their older counterparts we're not told
how they get there we're not told who
sent them there now the general idea
seems to be that this question is going
to be answered in Marvel legacy number
one the one shot that's setting the
stage for everything that comes after
secret Empire but of course this is
basically Jason Aaron sort of hitting at
the crowd that doesn't like Jane Foster
versus the crowd that does and it's
really just like Odin's son's reaction
is saying how could a woman possibly
wield the hammer of Thor now that's a
little heavy-handed but still you know
it's this it's really just kind of that
reaction of how could you possibly lift
the hammer that belongs to me what this
does is it of course has the two of them
teaming up kind of putting their
differences aside for a second and
ultimately teaming up now as powerful as
apocalypse is he's not able to stand
against both of them now again that's
kind of the funny thing about this
apocalypse is one of those villains in
Marvel Comics where he is as powerful as
he needs to be within any particular
story but up to a certain point the guy
can basically do everything but there's
limits to how far his power can go in
terms of what he can do like he's some
point if apocalypse were to fight Thanos
for example Thanos would probably just
trash him oh yeah I really can't think
of a scenario where apocalypse would
remotely stand a chance against Thanos
regardless of the circumstances of
course it's basically Odin's son facing
off against these soldiers of apocalypse
and then of course Jane Foster trying to
face off against apocalypse himself now
for the most part they're pretty readily
able to hold their own as powerful as
apocalypse is apocalypse just is not
able to
stand against both and again this is not
unestablished territory and the whole
uncanny Avengers story with Odin's son
using the enchanted battle ax of Yaran
he was able to almost cut off the arm of
apocalypse so you know that battle axe
is being used now in conjunction with
the hammer
basically just sends apocalypse really I
mean it's really it now we don't really
find out what happens to him and we're
just kind of left to you know basically
be told he's defeated and that's really
about it the focus of the story isn't
necessarily the Battle of apocalypse
mean there's no way he can go against to
Thor's you know and presumably win but
at the same time he also kind of could
the most insane display of his power
came during the secret war story came
during the final battle that was written
by Jonathan Hickman going into all-new
all-different marvel and in that story
remember they had the Thor core which
was basically all these different
characters that existed throughout the
multiverse of Marvel Comics who had been
chosen to lift the hammer of Thor and
they were basically the police force of
battle world but the idea here is that
in this final battle of pocalypse
fought an army of Thor's like he fought
so many of them and like wrecked them
all so because of that I mean there's
precedents for him winning now for the
sake of this story of course he ends up
losing just because of the fact that you
know it's like well hey he's got to lose
but ultimately again this feeds back
into the Thor son of Asgard story
because where the norms had originally
told Odin a son hey look you're going to
save SIF you're gonna disobey your
father's orders you're gonna battle
frost giants you're gonna save sis life
and then you're gonna be worthy of
wielding the hammer in this case it is
the same message but by a different
means he's already disobeyed the orders
of his father he already raced off and
fought some unbelievable foe which is
basically apocalypse and then he you
know ends up saving the life of well
really just the Vikings cuz they would
have just been obliterated by apocalypse
but then it's really Jane Foster coming
along and saying you will lift your
hammer I know you will lift your hammer
because it's by virtue of you that I
learned what it meant to wield a hammer
and that's why I say this that's the
reason why Jane Foster story is so cool
the idea here is that with Jane Foster
she learned how to become four by
watching Thor by watching Odin's son be
a superhero
she was literally just following in his
footsteps now her story is a lot more
diverse and a lot more intriguing
because instead of just picking up the
hammer one day in sync now let's go
fight with the Avengers suddenly it was
she picks up the hammer
she dawns Thor she's fighting a battle
against everybody in a scar that says
you're not really
you don't have the right to lift that
hammer as well as funny against the
various enemies and forces of her own
story and the Avengers and so on and so
forth so that's why I say her story as
short as it's going to be it's pretty
interesting and it's still pretty fun to
check out because there's so much that
goes on again it's one of those cool
situations when it comes to like the
character of Odin's son and his
progression over the years versus Jane
Foster's progression as short as it's
been but with this particular thing what
this does it is actually ends on a
pretty huge reveal and what we end up
finding out here is that Odin and the
Phoenix force apparently had a
relationship at some point in the past
now this is kind of weird here this is
all new territory for those of you guys
who are not familiar with the origin of
the Phoenix force that origin was given
in Excalibur and I cannot remember then
the issue for the life of me but the
idea here is that the Phoenix force
represents the sum total of all life in
the multiverse that's why it is that you
have one Phoenix force that exists
throughout the multiverse and different
people will be a host for the Phoenix in
different universes now how that
universe unfolds is entirely different
when it comes to the origin of the
Phoenix all we ever really knew was that
there was just like a sorcerer supreme
from a different universe and this guy
basically wanted to converge all the
universes into one and give himself
absolute power and because the Phoenix
force had never really tasted mortal
whims and watts which meant that the
Phoenix force had never really
encountered mortal beings when the
Phoenix force encountered this sorcerer
supreme
it basically duped her like it it preyed
on the fact that the Phoenix was
extremely naive and so it was like hey
look establish these little pillars
around these different universes and
then all will be well and then once the
Phoenix realized what was going on it
destroyed everything it basically
eliminated these pillars and then took
off now then of course leads into the
Phoenix eventually encountering Jean
Grey but there's never been an instance
in the history of Marvel Comics that
ever indicated the Phoenix and Odin ever
had any measure of a relationship again
this is all new stuff now again this
leads into Marvel legacy and is setting
the stage for what happens next
going into the line of Thor stories at
least this tale bit with regards to Odin
most likely does I mean the whole part
of like unworthy Thor meeting Jane
Foster
that's just tying the story for the sake
of a story anyway if you guys are new
here to comics explain and make sure you
guys hit the sub button to become part
of the Rob core if you guys enjoy this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later please
[Music]
you